hearing will come back to order counsel
I neglected to do this at the early part
and I apologize not because I wanted to
ignore you but would you just identify
yourself for the record
Sheldon llaves I'm from Miami Florida
I'm an attorney for mr. badson
you've been representing him for some
time since 1984 thank you very much
appreciate it
now mr. Betts 'nor you said just before
the break that there came a time when
you lost a flight and the result was
that you got a little nervous about the
operation and you have essentially
retired for the second time from the
business is that accurate that's
accurate
where did you go to during this second
retirement I went to Hawaii how long
were you there for
I stayed there until July of what year
of 84 okay
and it's sometime did George Morales
call you yes he did what did he call you
for can you pull the mic a little bit
close to you there just if you can he
told me he needed had something for me
to do that was very important did he
explain to you what it was as best he
could over the telephone we were very
cautious about the phone and he said it
if I would come back how that he could I
could be very beneficial in helping him
I get out from under his indictment hey
you know this time you knew that George
Morales was indicted is that accurate
yes sir
and George specifically said you could
help me get out from under my indictment
that right so did you fly back to
Florida I guess I did what did you do
when you got to Florida I met with
George and he gave me the rundown on the
whole thing what did George say to you
about the whole thing he said that he
had made a deal with CIA to supply them
with money and with assistance and that
he wanted me to fly some
guns and ammunition stuff like that down
to the Contras and and bring some
contraband back here you're absolutely
positive about this this is what George
Morales said to you yes he gave me the
general rundown that this is what was
happening yes what was your reaction to
that I said what give me the details
you know what is it you need done i-i-i
didn't really like i didn't want to do
it but i always loved and respected
George because he took me in and he
trusted me when I was like an orphaned
you know and so one good turn does
another and loyalty is something that we
all learned to respect in our lives and
so he gave me the rundown this situation
they didn't seem to be too difficult and
seemed to be covered and and I always
took George for his word I mean many
times I was amazed that some of the
things that he said would take place
that actually took place and so over the
years and through experiences where you
risk your life in other people's hands
you eventually learn to trust people and
especially when you're handling large
sums of money and you know in the
millions of dollars and they're
transacted and held in a parking lot and
it's not like the business world whereby
you have to have contracts and then you
still might get taken advantage of I
mean our business was a business where
your word is your bond and so not to
elaborate too much he gave me the
rundown on what he wanted done and it
seemed pretty simple to me and so I
agreed to do it
was this the first time that you'd heard
mention of CIA or Contras from George
yes it wasn't something that was
generally carried on in conversation or
you sit around the office to talk about
I would say I knew that Georgia had
connections in the past I never had
talked to him about it
and I knew I can't say that I knew I
suspected that he had some connections
with some government officials at
time-to-time and did you then agree to
do this flight yes right okay when did
this flight take place I think in July
was July of 84 sometime summer late
summer you know mid summer what kind of
airplane did you use the first time was
a Cessna and the second time was a
panther and where did the flight
originated from the first one was out of
Fort Lauderdale what was loaded into
that flight that particular flight had
an m60 machine gun other m16 guns as I
recall I didn't see any like any new
packaging it was a looked like it was
put together a mr. package pack is
neatly but it wasn't like you know right
from the factory time stuff and this is
in what kind of airplane cessna 402c now
if this was packaged how did you know
what was in the packages because I had
to go in the back door and climb over
the stuff it didn't have a pilot's door
in the front of the aircraft you knew
identified it by the packages or you
actually saw well when I offloaded it I
got to see most of what was there there
was some c4 explosive you know plastic
explosive this was loaded at the Fort
Lauderdale Florida Airport that's where
I think that the aircraft during the
daytime know I left about midnight who
left with you Tito who is Tito I he had
flown with me
several different times in the past when
I worked for George he was a Colombian
young fellow who was a trustee of George
he flew from Fort Lauderdale have a
permit for those weapons that you left
the country with I know sir of course
not
he had no paperwork no you took those
weapons and flew to where I flew to
Costa Rica to the ranch of one mr. John
Hall did you know who John Hall was not
until I met him at the year and his
Airport had you ever met him previously
no I haven't okay can you just take a
moment to walk over to the map and
identify the exact location that you
landed at on this first flight in Costa
Rica oh yes
is that an identified strip on that
flight map
why don't you come back to the
microphone so you can speak and identify
that the place that you just identified
is actually an identified strip on that
map which says what John hull that's a
small circle showing an airstrip is that
accurate yes
that's part of his ranch it's on his
ranch it's right on the river had you
ever been there before no Sara Helen
how did you and that was where you were
instructed to land yes he left at
midnight what time did you arrive there
well I would say probably 7:00 in the
morning and when I neared the coast of
Costa Rica after I picked up the vor out
of San Jose I was about 8,000 feet and
the Sun was coming up and so I just send
it down there was a slight overcast once
they'd broken - scattered about 1,500
feet
I stayed above that until a loss to vor
over the mountains from San Jose and
then I went to my chart that I had of
that area and went directly to the strip
by following landmarks when I was about
10 minutes out I called them on a
frequency that I had and they replied
and so I went to that strip and can you
describe the strip to us well when I
when I entered the pattern to join the
strip I flew south of the strip over a
bridge which was one of my landmarks and
there there's a bend in the river to
sharp bend in the river actually I
circled west of the airstrip and when I
first saw it over a pasture and I made a
right-hand pattern and landed in a strip
his trips a little over 3,000 feet long
with a what is known as a dogleg that
kind of curves to the west on the north
end and there's some bushes on that end
of this trip the strip runs right along
the river
the north end is right on the river the
middle of this trip is a problem 100
yards or so from the river to kind of a
big sandbar that extends down to the
river and several small trees there's a
road that runs down the center of the
strip
well actually it's over on the west side
a fence on the west side as I recall I
landed it tax it to the end he was there
they say he John Hall and some blond
headed guy younger fellow and two Latins
were there any vehicles around as I
recall there was a Japanese Datsun truck
or something like that with a funny
thing on the back of it and there was a
big truck that we offloaded the weapons
into you know like a ton and a half
truck or something when you got out of
the aircraft and stopped the engines did
did he identify himself to you how did
you know yes I walked up to him shook
his hand he introduced himself
introduced myself what do you look like
he's an older guy about 60 65
bald-headed I think he had blue eyes
about 200 pounds I guess maybe a little
about 200 pounds and about my height
maybe a little bit shorter and one was
gonna say like hey you know okay I
identified his pictures and you have a
conversation oh yes we talked about he
said he was from Indiana that had been
down there for a few years 10 or 15
years something like that
did you help offload the weapons no I
did not I stood there while they were
being offloaded but I didn't have to
these other guys did it I just stood
there you know protect the aircraft and
watch the aircraft that was mine you saw
them being offloaded yes how long did
that operation take oh about an hour and
a half we didn't get in a real big hurry
and we had to he had the gas was there
in barrels he said he had a truck but
ahead of some of the kind of fuel on it
so we often pumped out of the barrels
had a nice pump and filter and the works
so I filled up not only used about two
hundred and thirty gallons or something
like that going down there do you get
introduced to the blond haired person no
I did not after the guns were unloaded
was something loaded into the airplane
yes I loaded about seventeen duffel bags
and five or six two foot square boxes in
the aircraft what was in the duffel bags
coca cocaine and in the boxes cocaine it
was John hull there while you loaded it
in yes he was did he or anybody explain
to you what you were loading or did you
know I knew how did you know because I
was told before I was I left then I
would be bringing coke back I mean you
know in Georgia wasn't sent me out to I
mean I knew what the risk and Bob and
what was involved before I took the job
how much were you getting paid for that
John well we didn't really discuss it I
mean we went into it and and George says
well I'm doing it for nothing really
aces I'm just doing it for nothing and
and you're the only pile that I know
that can bring it all the way back in
and you know and he said if you have any
problems when you come back in there'd
be somebody to cover for you I said
don't worry I won't have any problems
and he said well there'd be no problems
today everything's covered and you won't
have any problems
what do you mean everything is covered
or there'll be somebody there to cover
for you well you know the customs are
DEA followed me and when I landed
aircraft I wouldn't have any problems I
mean I would they wouldn't bother me and
he ever said anything like that to you
before no had that been true of any of
your other flights as a drug smuggler no
were you surprised by it did you ask him
what he meant no actually I wasn't
surprised by it because I knew that that
George was a anti-communist as our most
Colombians so the cartel and people like
that are definitely anti-communist - I
don't suppose their world would function
too well in a communist
less strictly a capitalist movement miss
drug business so and George has never
lied to me
George is a kind of guy if he tells you
the sun's not coming up tomorrow you can
place your bet on it you know now with
respect to the cartel that you just
mentioned did you have occasion to meet
Barry seal you don't already own several
different occasions you know he was an
affable guy named a little guy but I
felt like some of the people that he
knew that he was playing both sides and
I had been told that so when I see him
coming I'd usually go the other way
where did you first meet Barry sale the
first time I met him was in Nassau and
you meet him subsequently yes I run into
him one time in Miami and another time
at and up in Pennsylvania where at
Pennsylvania in here America and where
you say he played both sides what was
your understanding of what Barry seal
was involved in that he was wouldn't
involved with the CIA
our DEA but CIA was the indication that
I got and did you come at some point to
you mentioned something about the cartel
and its support did you learn anything
from your friends in the Cuban community
or elsewhere about cartel support of the
Contras yes this a lot of the Cubans
that I worked with were marielle and a
lot of them were they a fixed type
people you know went long ways back and
they were fervent anti-communist that's
what would that they were into and of
course the ones that I knew were
smugglers those are the only people that
I knew I didn't know anybody outside
that type of those type of people and
were those smugglers at that time
assisting in any way that you knew of
only by I can surmise but nothing that I
know are there actually witnessed no
nothing that you saw no sir but things
you heard oh yes sir okay now how long
did it take to load the flight with the
cocaine ten minutes then what did you do
I walked around the aircraft sir my
looked at his airstrip I had doubts
about his trip so we after we gassed and
loaded aircraft on I we pushed the
aircraft back actually tied to tied a
rope on the back of it as I recall now
and we pushed it back to the road in the
center of the strip and whose directly
down the strip was a building so I had
to go over west of the building and the
grass hadn't been motivating well there
it was kind of tall and but anyway I
backed up as far as I could and then I
ran the in tubs and rains it ran the
engines up had an extra 75 80 yards
there you know and I got a pretty good
roll and put the flaps down about
halfway down the strip pull the aircraft
off the ground just as it broke ground
and pulled the gear up and you know I
made it all right and turned across the
river and headed out but it wasn't that
was a kind of Harry he flew back to
where I was coming back to supposed to
come back into Fort Lauderdale Executive
and I got cold feet started thinking
about it so when I got back why did you
get cold feet well I just never had I
was always been very cautious and I
never had gone back into an airport in
the United States to a controlled field
i always landed in the middle of fields
in the middle of night with night-vision
goggles on all parameters and and
everything was covered and police were
paid off and everything was you know
together and this this was a little bit
out of my this was a bold daylight
supposedly cleared to land and that's
what George had in foreign
right well you know but you got cold
feet notwithstanding that right so I
have my own operation in Lakeland I had
a hangar there so I had enough fuel when
I got back so I just went on to Lakeland
and I've loaded their coke in my van and
had Tito drive it back to Miami and I
kept winged kilos from my my my part
subsequent did that to George Morales
ask you to do anything else for it in
what regard senator I mean after that
after that flight yes a week or ten days
later so I did another one and this time
I used the panther after explaining to
George the 402 wasn't the machine for
that job and especially how that strip
and that if that guy was gonna be in
that kind of business he needs to have a
better strip and I had a coordinates for
these trips and also I had a map with a
circle around it and the alternate when
I went down the first time was lost
Jonas and I hadn't seen the strip but I
knew Sean has a strip right near the
John Hall strip well probably 10 or 10
miles or so away maybe it'll further a
little less you know how to spell I shot
us la la nos you know and it's a lowland
area near as I found out now it's The
Voice of America towers
it's about I'd say three quarters a mile
from the towers east you know give or
take a quarter mile or so no let's let's
go back to the beginning of what airport
did you leave from this time I left from
overlocker opa-locka Airport that's
correct
where was the plane loaded it was loaded
right in aviation activities right and
right there in his in his hangar you
know at in George Morales hangar right
when I got there it was pulled outside
and it was loaded to the ceiling that
that was a good load it had a pilot's
door on it so
just got in it Tito went with me again
and we departed about 11:30 12:00
o'clock that night
what was this load about the same
configuration small arms no ammunition I
know awful there's a lot of small arms
you know again did you have any permit
or any paperwork for that I think there
were some mines I think there were some
mines yeah clear that was George but I
believe there were some land mines or
something there that would come and you
again the answer on the paperwork no
permits no permissions that's right no
permits no permission did George say
anything again this time about where you
should land and where you should return
to yeah I think he did he I supposed to
come right back to overlocker and just
tack see up to that a hangar no problem
did you then fly down to John Hall's
ranch I didn't go to John Hawes home
place I went to this other strip called
leshawna's and when I got there I called
and and that's where they were they were
their day and they being who John huh
and who else and two Latins just John
Hill and two Latins as I recall there
was a pickup truck setting up the road I
mean this is the first time I brought
that out but I saw a truck sitting up
the road there I don't know I don't know
who was in it but there was a truck
sitting up the road about it it's around
the strip just north what time of day
did you arrive this time I got there
early in the morning at the same time
what did this strip look like this strip
was in the middle of a lowland area
there were no trees and there were
tropical trees across the road on the on
the south end of the strip
I believe this trip laid Southwest North
East to the southeast of this trip were
some low-lying Hills and there was four
towers directly west of the strip there
was a road that runs south of the strip
around to the north
and his red looked like clay or
something
there were drainage ditches cut
perpendicular to the airstrip on both
sides as I said before there are no
trees around that I can recall you said
you recalled some towers
yes sir and there were towers west of
there we're with the towers how far away
I'd say about 3/4 of a mile what kind of
what what sort of towers very tall
towers maybe 2 or 300 feet tall how many
4 of them do you know what they were
Voice of America when you land it did
you again have a discussion with mr.
John hull yeah Justin hi how you doing
did you supervise the offloading no
again I stood there and what it was
offloaded did John Hall supervise the
offloading no he just stood back and
they took care of everything the two
Latins right okay and where were the did
you load anything into the plane after
that yes I loaded cocaine in the plane
with the same configuration except this
time there wasn't any boxes it was all
in the duffle bags how many duffle bags
I would say probably 17 or 15 17 each of
them held about 30 kilos I I estimated
around 500 kilos and when when you land
it where was the where were the duffle
bags at the time you were doing the
offloading they were in the trunk they
had had a different truck with a
fuelling truck there with had a
compartment in it that's where most of
the bags were who loaded the bags into
the plane now they were handed to me and
I stacked them so you could load them
correctly yes sir
and again the total load was how much
approximately 500 kilos value of those
500 kilos wholesale at that time
wholesale the goes all in different
levels uh some people say it was 20,000
and other people were host sailing for
35,000 depends on who and wearing a
tequila yeah per kilo yes sir
and you had 500 kilos yes so a low-end
twenty five twenty thousand high-end of
35,000 right at that point in time that
point yes
you know where that cocaine came from no
I would know precisely where he came
from but it was like all the cocaine up
I picked up in Colombia was a package
the same way
subsequent to your flight once you've
gotten back
did you hear something about where that
cocaine had come from or one of the
loads that you had picked up from John
Hall's ranch I don't understand what
you're getting at there Sara did you
learn anything about the about what
might have taken place with respect to
mr. hull and one of those cocaine loads
Oh are you talking about the kidnapping
and stuff I'm asking you if I had heard
something about that but I heard about
that after a long after that I I did
these two loads with Allah how long
after I since I've been arrested no
since I ran into Georgia after all this
came out that's when I found out about
it
just for the record because there are
others who have testified to this I'd
like to know what it was that you heard
I just heard that uh that John Hall had
ripped off some a coke off of a boat or
something or a plane is something that
sunken and the people knew he had it and
they kidnapped one of his kids in order
to get it back or something that's
basically I don't know all the details I
mean just in passing conversation do you
know where you had that passing
conversation no sir it must have been
down at MCC it's been a while
the record should so show that
record should show that the same story
has been told by both Jose bland own and
and mr. Floyd Carlton who was one of
general Noriega z' pilots who testified
to it in some detail to what took place
do you know fort Colton I know sir I
don't I know of him you've never met him
another I would call no I've seen his
picture I don't think so let me let me
at this point in time introduce into the
record
this is an unclassified now unclassified
letter from the Department of the
Treasury
the US Customs Service a letter from
Rochelle Lopez to mr. Ralph Martin
Department of Justice Public Integrity
attorney in 1986 my staff released a
report in which many of the details
though some of them sketchy but many of
the details of the story we are hearing
today as well as other allegations were
laid out and set forth in considerable
detail the majority of those allegations
perhaps 95% of them have now been proven
and carried out through the iran-contra
committees select investigation in
addition to the testimony before this
committee over the course of the last
months however when that report was sent
down there prior to the iran-contra news
being made public a check was run on our
report and in the letter it says as
explained the data provided in senator
Kerry's report was cross-checked with
the criminal indices of the Treasury
enforcement communications system and
headquarters files in additions customs
officers of enforcement in Miami in
Atlanta were contacted for your
information tecs which is the
enforcement communication system records
are indexed by name and other
identifying data TECs query of the names
furnished that is in our report resulted
in 21 matches there were however
numerous instances in which matches
could not be refined as they were too
many records in the universe for example
the name John hull resulted in 293
possible matches consequently without
further identifying data we are not be
able to determine if
record exists for some of the persons
named subsequent to this a subsequent to
learning that mr. halls name had turned
up 293 times
this was classified and no further
investigation was made mr. Hall was
continued to permit to operate with
impunity in fact to the point that he
filed false affidavits with the United
States attorney concerning this senator
and our investigation while continuing
to work with agencies the United States
government
mr. Hall has been under subpoena by this
committee for I think eight months and
he continues to avoid presenting himself
to this committee so many questions are
raised by the entire set of
circumstances surrounding mr. hulls
activities in the region as well as in
these events which have been set forward
here and I personally am disturbed by
the fact that these allegations have sat
out there for as long as they have with
as little law enforcement follow-up and
investigative effort and enough said on
that mr. Benson er let me come back to
the second flight you loaded with
narcotics and you flew back to the
United States correct mr. okay mm-hmm
was that your last drug flight it's the
last one a different George did you make
any money off that flight no yes I made
about 360,000 you say it's the last
flight you did for George that's correct
did you do some more flights for
yourself yes I left and went back to
Hawaii and I had met this lady and had
fallen in love and and we were going to
be married and and we're back in Hawaii
and I had another friend
and I may be an offer and I couldn't
refuse it and so that's I was
subsequently arrested in busted is this
this next offer was another drug flight
yes okay from where to where from
Columbia to Lake City Florida what kind
of aircraft Panther now this flight took
place when November 13th and 14th of 84
and you were arrested when at that time
the 14th at the airport I know I got
away from the airport but I was
subsequently apprehended in the city and
incarcerated and you were indicted for
for four counts and conspiracy to import
cocaine that is the sentence that you're
now serving yes sir I received 15 years
for that plus 10 years special for all
and then later went back to Miami when I
got there I pleaded guilty to the bond
jumping and the case that I had in Miami
that was then at about 10 years old and
received a consecutive sentence on top
of my 15 so your total sentence you're
serving now is what 27 years and two
months and you did in fact marry this
woman that you met yes I did and by
previous marriage you have kids do you
not yes sir I have five children
now you still own a farm in Arkansas no
sir I don't
and there was a period of time in your
life when you were in Arkansas as a crop
duster that you were involved in a lot
of activities isn't that accurate yes
sir
supported candidates for office
campaigns I was you know was active in
my community and kids I grew up with and
played ball with and against and knew
them all of my life I was president of
JC's we had a nice JC Club in those days
I was a County coordinator for our
senator Dale bumpers at the time I was
also on executive committee the young
Democrat club and I was and when
Rockefeller ran I was in college I was
an executive committee of the Republican
Party and I was always interested in in
civic things you know a good citizen as
a matter of fact my political views in
those days were somewhere to the right
of the John Birch Society has where most
of my friends in those days now
mr. Fetzer let me come back to a couple
things I'd like to get out and let me
just offer you the opportunity here
because I you know what you've said is
very important testimony and it's very
significant and obviously you've pointed
some heavy fingers in a few directions
is there anything in here that's that
shaded something you want to change
anything you feel ought to be restated
or anything that you somehow are
uncomfortable with having said it mm no
sir none whatsoever I wish I had been
more I wish I were been in a situation
where I could have kept notes and times
and dates and places and you know I've
often wished I could have done that but
in my business I was not able to do that
the one of the things I'd like to get at
slightly outside of the other subject is
the whole notion of the efforts to try
to
one or two other questions if I can do
you have current feelings about what's
happening in Central America do you have
any political feelings about the war I'm
a senator I I somewhere within sight of
me I have a deep appreciation of of my
country its history the Constitution
what it stands for still move my soul
considerably after when you know
standing on one side of the fence
looking at it at a situation it looks
one way and you go on the other side you
look at it it looks another way so do I
have any feelings about it I think that
with the proper leadership and and the
genuine carrying it was some common
sense all of these things in Central and
South America could have been avoided
long time ago after all they are you
know connected to us and so I am NOT a
policymaker and I'm not a politician I
understand that I'm not trying to ask
you to go into that but just you know in
a short sort of answer were you
personally supportive of the Contras do
you dislike the Sandinistas did you feel
like you were taking sides or was it
irrelevant to you well I was sympathetic
for the Contras yes now one last area I
just want to ask you about the question
of evasive tactics flying all these
flights 1983-84 were conscious of the
drug problem in this country we're
spending money on enforcement and
interdiction you seem to fly in and out
with fair impunity
you know how are you able to do that
well I made it a science
I had knowledge and background
electronics and electronic
countermeasures which means knowing how
I know the fingerprints are radar
our works and that sort of thing and so
I spent time in my aircraft and and with
my detecting devices I even built radar
detectors and sold them and we would I
would go down the coast I wasn't too
concerned about the East Coast of
Florida it was pretty easy but you had
to come through an array a net of
surveillance that somewhere along the
line you might be detected and followed
in so if you really wanted to come in
incognito at any time of the day really
all you need to do was I'd be able to
fly below the horizon under the radar
come up into the blind spot between the
radars and then as you get in there
shore always try to be having a hitting
that is southerly instead of coming from
the from the south be coming from the
north and you just penetrate I had my
aircraft painted dark green and the
windows were tinted so you couldn't see
any aircraft and I had tape numbers I
just take the numbers off and I tried to
come in about 30 minutes before dark and
I wasn't unable to do that by having an
Omega system on my aircraft or in Iran
but Omega was really nice and I could
pinpoint myself within 50 feet anywhere
on the earth and fly accordingly and so
it was very simple to do I have one of
my first flights I came in on the East
Coast and just to test my theory and I
had the good fortune of picking up the
customs what they call the citation what
the infrared does that device on it and
I don't know if the egg wax was tracking
or not I think it was and then I had two
aircraft and one on each wingtip escort
me and from East of Andros they picked
me up coming through the pass one word
passed down over 80 and I just came in
my computer
I just came in about 30 minutes after
sundown overnight at Miami Beach and and
lost them I did a couple of times
how'd you lose them that particular time
I think and I came in went between the
condominiums and glue down the end of
the waterway there it's very dark listen
to him on his scanner what they were
doing and I wasn't too sure about to a
whack so I went on out to the
International Airport and as I said yeah
my aircraft was dark green I fell up
under an aircraft that was on the ILS
and he was about 800 feet or so I just
pulled up under him for the fun out of
it and following him down the runway and
when he landed I just pulled up over in
him and flew down the runway and buzz
the tower and and we went over to the
beach and gone up north you know no big
deal
was there an occasion that AWACS did
pick you up yes my last trip was that
they tracked me this one I knew someone
had probably had an informer somewhere I
mean I suspected it at that moment when
I left Colombia and I was being on track
being tracked by a wax and so I just
went out and flew to Haiti and then I
went down over Haiti I went through the
valleys and over bike a patient and then
I'm live on the water through a
thunderstorm out too great an agua and I
stayed east of the islands about 20 foot
off the water below the cliffs all the
way up through the chain of the islands
and I listened to him on my scanner and
I they lost me and they didn't pick me
up and I later found out the informant
in my case was in Ricky Lopez or Henry
Lopez you were arrested through an
informant operation yeah my old friend
Henry Lopez was the informant and as a
matter of fact he still owes me a
million dollars maybe I was my informed
oh me
but he and Jairo Plata so he knew that
there were supposed to be 500 kilos on
the plane and he and he wondered why
there was only a 300 pounds so anyway he
was the one that did it you know
Here I am are there occasions you've
come to know the informant world and the
smuggler world obviously both of them
very well do you know of occasions where
informants are working both sides while
informing yes I know of several maybe
five different groups that are involved
I can't give you exact specifics on it
maybe if we had a lot of time perhaps
but I know of one specific group that I
had worked with and that's Henry Lopez
in real Oh PES has been smuggling since
there's I now understand he was working
with him in 81 since Kojak went to work
for them but I didn't know that at the
time I was working with him there was an
informant and George always said he was
but George was we all have our
paranoia's and one or two final
questions as we try to deal with this
issue of the drug war and we're trying
to allocate money and decide where it
goes and how to do it obviously one of
the things people keep looking at is is
a multi-front effort enforcement
interdiction education and so forth
you obviously have a certain disdain for
the notion that interdiction is going to
be very effective can it be more
effective than it is is it necessary
that people always work through as
easily as you did well yes sir I think
that the human mind is a very ingenious
thing as you know and we have if you
count of Hawaii in Alaska we have over
20,000 miles of a parameter you know
almost the circumference of the earth -
in Iran and and the prophets that are in
this is very are enormous and there are
people who don't want to stop the drug
trade obviously we can see that
there's a there's emerging at the top
with the underworld and there's billions
and billions of dollars being made here
and this is not something new as history
tells us that's been going on since the
opium wars to me is the 21st century I'm
just talking from my own experience I'm
not talking from what somebody said
frankly I'm alive and I tried about
everything and I'm fortunate to have
because I'm able to explain to my
children and I'll never have a problem
with my kids in those areas so I think
the name of the game is take the profit
out of it legalize it
edie licensed people beings that we live
in a controlled society we do and we're
all different make people buy a license
and if they're caught with it without a
license and without going to school
without being educated then then find
them or do whatever we punish them it is
necessary to those people if we bust
arrest and incarcerate 4 million people
and we give each one of them 10 years
which is about happening what's about
just about happened in the last 20 years
for drugs and that's 40 million years
and say an average life expectancy and
in the 21st century is 80 years divide
that into four million and we have 500
thousand lifetimes a wasted you know and
for what I want to thank you for sharing
the experiences that you've had with us
and I particularly want to thank being
willing to obviously take the risk which
is involved with this and let this
committee know of what's happened and I
just want you to know that the subpoena
which you're currently under will
continue to be in effect until such time
as the committee decides it doesn't need
you further with respect to this we are
going to take a ten-minute recess and
when we come back we're going to proceed
to go with the videotapes of three
Nicaraguan exiles in Costa Rica who will
testify further to some of the things
that mr. Betts nor has discussed and to
their involvement in this particular
sequence so we stand in recess for ten
minutes